i'm gonna i'm gonna cut them some slack
and say
maybe it's not joe biden so maybe voting
for him it's not really the problem i'm
kidding by the way but now i'm going to
reference this story from fox business
elon musk slams biden the real president
is whoever controls the teleprompter
musk also warned that the u.s ignores
obvious cause of inflation it could end
up like venezuela and he went on to say
that someone could bump the teleprompter
and then biden would just read it like
ron burgundy
so what i'm going to say is it's true we
can't blame those who are supporting joe
biden because joe biden isn't the
president whoever controls a
teleprompter is but well if you put joe
biden there and he is being directed by
somebody else then you voted for this
you voted for the war can we also talk
about my favorite part of that story was
it was on fox news uh before the show
and the fox news anchor had to
essentially explain what the movie
anchorman was he's like it is a
satirical line from a comedy movie where
laughter ensues
well you know the average uh i think
what's the average age of fox and news
viewers my grandma 62 or something
what's the what's the round burgundy the
anchor ranger it's a comedy movie oh
shout out to my grandma who sent me a
happy birthday text i did not have her
saved in my phone but this but we got
toxic family stuff because i guess the
whole show today is just like literally
elon musk's daily business dude he's
just
loving life right now yeah that's great
isn't it just
i gotta i i gotta look i gotta i gotta
throw back to this one because
while we're doing the show
he responded to benny johnson who
tweeted about the the the
guy saying wokeness cost them money and
he made the like
was it like a depressed sad face
i'm just gonna say this they hurt his
feelings the guy insulted him for having
asperger's i think james o'keefe may
have just saved elon musk like 10
billion dollars i think so maybe 20
billion dollars
these videos coming out right now i will
i believe
i'm just i'm not a lawyer but it sounds
like it could give elon musk an actual
legal argument
as to uh to negotiating a lower price
or even having the contract contract be
broken no fee
so if if either if elon breaks the
twitter bio contract he's got to pay a
billion dollars
if twitter breaks the contract they got
to pay him a billion dollars oh my god
with these videos coming out elon's
clearly seen them both
he can probably go to a court and say
they did not disclose to me these things
elon's kind of made twitter fun again
yeah yeah yes yeah it's like almost like
trump yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah man
twitter was so fun under trump
when people even i mean i was i was not
a trump supporter i was still pretty
progressive but if you are really gonna
look me in the eye and say when the
democratic debate was going on and trump
just tweeted boring and okay that that
wasn't the funniest thing in the world
you're a liar you are a liar well i mean
coffee yes it's got its own wikipedia
entry
and it said despite the negative press
coffee
and
i think they were right despite the
negative press coverage but then
mashed it with their thumb and
accidentally sent it or like put in
their pocket and it went off something
happened and we got the word coffee just
delightful it was great who was it was
it michael malus or am i mr remembering
who said something like congratulations
to all the former trump reply guys who
can be elon musk reply guys that's very
funny that sounds like a malice thing
but i don't know i don't know man
i wonder if the elon musk deal will
actually end up going through now yeah
kind of crazy who knows maybe he put
project veritas up to this so he could
get out of it he's like this is a mess i
don't want any part of it i love him
[Laughter]
so then in the skit james takes his mask
off and it's eel on the whole
yep yep yep no i think it's fascinating
though um
i wonder if it i mean clearly this email
went out it looks like veritas
targeted twitter employees
recently
you know it was the end of april
beginning of may all this was going down
so it seems like
how elon musk might make save billions
of dollars thanks to the journalism of
project veritas have you met o'keefe
yeah yeah we've had one show several
times what's his deal
my golden chill dude yeah joel did
fascinating loves musicals yeah
really he does well turns out i'll get
along with him yeah yeah he was in uh
what was it oklahoma okay stop it yeah
oh yeah
he and
he was like the main dude wasn't i think
he was i think he was just doing an
undercover operation yeah that's what it
was
because
any time that's the thing anytime he
does anything that he could consider
embarrassing he's like it was an
operation it's an operation he just
busts in after i got so excited and so
gayle he was like he did oklahoma that's
my favorite they're like busted he's
like actually a bunch of feminists were
mad about me they spread that rumor it's
not true he's never in oklahoma
i love it no james is great yeah he
loves his singing dance he loves phil
collins he's fantastic dude yeah all
right
time to do some research on old james
o'keefe when i get home literally this
skit would be literally everything he
does as a sting so he's not like a
supermarket and he's like looking shifty
eyed as he like grabs a box of lucky
charms and like puts in his why why
lucky charms you know why
it's because you left a box of lucky
charms i did leave i'm not gonna lie i
did leave a box of lucky charms you're
not being yeah it was sent by a fan it
was sent by a fan it was sent by a fan
to be fair
so uh i wasn't opposed to it elon musk
is criticizing joe biden and i don't i
don't i don't know what else to say
other than
he's uh i i won
well i was gonna say something um
back to
what you were asking me with the
cancellation and i also do wonder if
elon with the i'm going to vote
republican is either trolling because
you don't know who you're voting for
there are horrible republicans or
there's also part where
i remember when i did start to go on the
right wing shows and you know five
people on twitter were like oh here we
go here comes grifter he's gonna go all
dave ruben and become super conservative
or whatever agree and for me
i didn't because i mean i thought about
it i was like maybe i am conservative
and then i did watch a ben shapiro video
and i was like nah damn it i'm not
and uh
but then
but
you are but he did destroy you he did
yeah you're like i got destroyed it's
not for me
do i have one you were gop curious i was
zero people so you're like turn the
lights real low you got under the covers
you put on bench here
that's literally
i mean the first time i heard jordan
peterson i thought he was just going to
be screaming to kill trans people and i
was like okay okay my heart was really
saying i was like i'm going to watch the
rogan and he was like make your bed and
i was like he was like should make my
bed he's like i don't like large women
on the cover
that's right
i also remember having this moment and
maybe this sounds pathetic but whatever
when i walked into some of those offices
and having
and this was you know i had girlfriends
but i hadn't really jumped back into a
social circle i wasn't doing comedy
i was kind of doing jiu jitsu but going
into these offices and having everyone
know me hug me not shame me women like
host of the show put their hands on my
shoulder and be like i'm sorry what
happened to you sweetie i'm like sorry
what happened to me but i'm i'm the bad
person i'm the monster there is
something about
when a pile-on happens and then the
other side is just
kind to you
and sometimes with an agenda but
sometimes just because
i know a lot of really nice
conservatives i mean
i've had conservatives put me up when i
was homeless and we agree on nothing
whereas all of my brooklyn woke friends
you didn't call are you telling
cafes or whatever
occupy wall street yeah i was physically
threatened numerous occasions i was
physically attacked three different
times you know during marches or at the
park and then i see a bunch of you know
trump supporters you know people with
shields or even flags i walk over and
they're like you want to grab a bite and
talk
and it's just like look man i don't have
to agree with with the conservatives but
if they're willing to sit down and have
a burger and say well i disagree let's
have a nice day right the other side is
like we brought crowbars right well i'll
take i'll take a step further when i
went on it's called the real ass podcast
louis jay gomez who from legion of
skanks his podcast again he has been
called a proud boy there was a gay
comic-con and the gay comic was like
asked him about his use of the the f
word the other f word and
lewis was like look i've said it forever
i've never said it towards a gay person
it's just the way i came up with comedy
but i tell young comics you know don't
say it i wouldn't say it and most
importantly and i know louis very well
and this is i can vouch for this he's
like if i ever saw a gay person being
called that i would step in and i would
do something about it to the guy who's
being homophobic whereas
any one of my old lefty friends if they
saw a gay person getting beat up they
would run away to the nearest starbucks
to maybe tweet about it yeah they would
write a blog post about it for sure i
was in portland
proud boys were marching they planned
march antifa decided to counter march
and confront them the police had to
separate the two groups the proud boys
started marching
proud boys group was you know
the people of different races were there
and i think it was mostly white people
probably and uh we got to this point
where all of a sudden antiques started
yelling racial slurs at the black proud
boy really yeah and there's videos of
antifa yelling racial slurs at police
there's a black cop and they're yelling
just rachel throws that racial slurs at
him so they start yelling a racial slur
at this uh this black proud boy and so
he breaks from the crowd and starts
going across the street
and they're they're yelling slurs like
they're i think they're yelling the n
word i think they're yelling uh uncle
you know i don't want to say it i don't
want to entertain it but they were
yelling like the n word and other
other words the c word whatever he goes
across the street another proud boy runs
up to him and grabs him and says don't
take the bait dude don't listen to them
and then he grabs him and says don't let
him don't let him make you hate man
you're my brother we're here together
man we love you we care about you and
then they put their hands together he's
like let's get to it let's let's let's
stay focused and they brought him back
in
there's a video it was an i uh uh an ice
protest
and antivo's outside and they're just
screaming the n-word at these black cops
yikes
yo man bad looks yeah occupy wall street
segregated people based on race
they you're in the in the caucus voting
system where they would be like okay the
everyone everyone got a working group or
a caucus your working group was the work
you did the caucus was your race or
gender or you know identity or whatever
they had the black caucus the asian
caucus latino caucus so you literally
were voting on resources based on your
racial group
well and i remember even
with ferguson and some of the black
lives matter protests there were also
black people stopping other a lot of
times white uh blm marchers from
vandalizing or from and
it should show you that
if you are on the right and think
everyone who has marched for black lives
matter is evil no there are really good
people who would do the exact same thing
if you think that there are proud boys
who are all violent no there are people
who will do
the right thing and again
if those voices were the ones that would
be highlighted more instead of the
fringes we would actually probably agree
on more than thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you